hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast combined
immunohistochemistry and RNA in situ
hybridisation to elucidate tumor
molecular heterogeneity in prostate
cancer presented by na la savate
Polynice ami he is a associate senior
scientist at the Henry Ford Health
System
I am Marjorie Torres of labyrinth and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by advanced
style Diagnostics for more information
about our sponsor visit a cg bio dial
bio calm before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen well answer
as many of your questions as your time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge so and don't just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at top right of the
presentation window we use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. malossi Baum Palani Sami I
will now turn the presentation over to
him hello everyone my name is the novice
even Colin saw me today I'll be talking
about combined immunohistochemistry and
their RNA in stew hybridization to study
the tumor molecular control unity in
prostate cancer the outline of my talk
is going to be first on the comparison
of RNA
the protein expression by University
chemistry and the RNA ish so this is
strictly for validating how comparable
our minds to hybridization is to
administer chemistry then I will show
you how we can detect the infusions and
prostate cancer as many of you know
there are many it's related inclusions
have been identified in prostate cancer
since we don't have good antibody for
all of the test infusions we have
developed the RNA in situ hybridization
procedure for the tissue level
expression of these genes and then by
using this method we show that how we
can combine both immunised chemistry and
RNA into the hybridization for the
detection of more than one markers in a
similar ionization experiment so with
this approach we will be able to study
the tumor molecular heterogeneity in
prostate cancer as we aware more than a
percent of the prostate cancer or
multifocal disease so we are trying to
understand and the genetic underpinnings
in the different tumor flow side by
combining this RNAs and humanistic
chemistry in a multiplex approach and
there are several non-coding RNA targets
have also been identified to be
specifically expressed in prostate
cancer since we cannot develop good
antibody for our non-coding RNAs so we
develop the RNAs to hybridization probes
for the detection of the non-coding RNA
tissue levels and last I would like to
show you how we can combine both DNA
fish and the RNAs if you are interested
in actually for the detection of two
molecular markers so all the data that I
am going to present in this presentation
is about prostate cancer research
connected in my laboratory and the both
RNA and the immunohistochemistry
procedures that i am going to show is
completely under the bright field cusco
publication so you know you can go up to
like four markers that can be detected
under the bright field without the need
to use the process so here as my
laboratory is one of the early adapters
of the technology of RNA instead of
hybridization back in 2010 about six or
seven years ago so i thought it will be
useful to share some of my experience as
useful tips for some of you who may be
just beginning to set up these are means
they have less in your laboratory are
some of you may be custard in start
using this technology I thought this
would be useful so I would recommend to
use freshly cut happy tissue sections
when you are doing RNA into the
hybridization slice that are cut within
about three months our idea and if they
are more than three months old I would
recommend actually test a small batch of
flight using a positive and a negative
control probes to assess the RNA
integrity and you can perform the RNA in
situ hybridization both by manual
methods and automatic methods so in our
laboratory we have actually used the
Ventana discovery XP the research
instrument or performing RNA it's a high
precision and then other important thing
that I would like to mention is if you
are planning to do both is a and RNA ish
to detect more than one targets and the
tissue of your interest I would
recommend actually testing both your
antibody and the individual RNA is broke
first
individually you know
make sure they are performing well
before combining them then another
important point is make sure that if you
are doing both is in ardèche make sure
to the RNA is first then to ASC not the
other way around and as I mentioned
before the DNA fish and RNA fish can be
performed on the same tissue as long as
you are writing and other important
thing is you know it is important to
know have simply a knowledge about the
location of the target market especially
when you are doing a multiplex sa like
the antibodies make sure that over here
you are expecting under staining nuclear
or Center plasma core membranous you
know like that you know we have a clear
knowledge it'll be easy to interpret
you are the sauce so these are some of
the important tips that I thought it
would be useful for beginners and if you
have any more questions please refer to
the links that I have provided at the
end of this slide where you will find
many useful tips that is more related to
the RNAs protocol
so now I'm going to talk about the
prostate cancer molecular markers how
you can actually detect these molecule
markers at the tissue level by combining
both immunity chemistry and our mates
with high precision as you can see there
are several markers that have been
identified in prostate cancer
particularly the s gene fusions like the
earth ET b 1e tv4 and ET b5 is or the
x-family gene rearrangements that are
detected at varying frequency and these
markers are expressed only in prostate
cancer and sometimes you will see in
high-grade pin low grade cancer as well
and these markers it is important note
that they express only when there is a
chromosome translocations the explosion
of these genes are activated by from
some translocations otherwise you don't
see any even basal level of expression
of this protein so that makes this ideal
for doing this type of experiments and
similarly we found another targets pink
one which is identified in about 10% of
the prostate cancer then the ETV sorry
the PCA 3-week at once lab 1 and KL k p1
is aadi non-coding RNA and targets that
are well characterized in prostate
cancer they are associated with some
prostate cancer development and its
outcome so since we have this kind of
variety of this markers so we are
interested in developing and methods
that can be routinely used for the
reliable detection of these markers at a
tissue level ok since we have these many
markers and non-coding RNA so we cannot
have we cannot develop a method that can
be performed by a singular poet say for
example we cannot do it just by image to
chemistry so we have to develop both our
names the hybridization and
immunohistochemistry depending on the
availability of the antibodies so here
for Earth and [ __ ] and
p10 we have good antibodies so this can
be used for a monastic emissary
so all of the markers we don't have good
antibodies and they can be detected only
by RNAs for hybridization so since we
have antibody for Earth baton and speak
one so we can actually do the dual color
or the three color administer chemistry
like combining p10 or X pink one or as
pink one pickin like that you can do
this combination we have bubbliest this
work and for ETV one into before an e TB
file we have to perform on the RMA s to
have a decision then similarly for all
the encoding our key targets we have to
be with only Army's position so having
developed both ISE and RNAs so we were
interested in studying in these markers
in a multiplex mode rather than studying
each market individually which will be
time-consuming laborious sometimes you
are limited with the availability of the
tissue specimens so for those reasons
you know we are trying to develop a
multiplex method that we can detect more
than one mark in a single experiment so
we have optimized the protocol which is
consistently working so we can't detect
approve for markers in a single
experiment by combining like two markers
for IAC and the two markers for RNA ich
so you will be able to do both do i HC
and the dual harness so that you will be
able to detect up to like four markers
in a single hybridizations which i will
show you the latter part of this
presentation so before going into the
details and so when we started using the
R means the hybridization so we need our
own due diligence experiments and to see
how RNA into the hybridization is
comparable to the most chemistry so for
that since as I mentioned before since
we have about antibody for a gene so we
got both antibody and we
develop the RNA into the hybridization
probe for Earth and then we were trying
to compare the performance of the RNAs
bacillus s emails to chemistry so the
next slide as you can see here I'm
showing a tissue sections where we
hybridized with the antibody where you
will see the specific staining of Earth
only in the tumor area and that is no
staining in the stroma or and in an ad
cancer you will see such a specific
staining with the humanistic chemistry
but when you do the RNA instead of
hybridization so you will be able to see
a similar result where as you can see
the RNA signals can be seen as distinct
punctate dots and you will see most of
this signal or the cytoplasm as
comparable to the image the chemistry
you will see the specific staining of
the RNA molecules won't be in the tumor
area and I think in the stroma heart of
the it okay so based on this you know we
are quite convinced that you know we can
perform both RNA into the hybridization
of the administer chemistry which is
quite comparable so if we don't have a
good antibody for any gene of your
interest I think RNA ish may be a viable
option to consider for doing the tissue
level expression of anything of your
interest so then based on the level of
expression of your target you will be
seeing a different level of RNA stain
so you will see when it is negative you
don't see any dots suppose if the
protein layer so the RNA level
expression is kind of low you will be
able to see when we link few dots then
if the level is moderate you will see
like multiple doors if it is higher you
will see more like diffused
you will see more like a diffused
pattern of signal okay so we developed
based on the level of expressions
you know we developed this RNA is the
hybridization scoring criteria which you
can add annually by zero to like one
plus two plus or triplets and for class
this will help you to score the RNAs but
I think recently there are methods have
been developed for digital quantitation
of the RNAs to have a decision where if
you have a slide and get it scanned the
high resolution scanning or a digital
imaging and that will help using digital
image processing software everywhere
that you'll be able to get a politician
of the RNA signal as well say that you
can do it manually or by the digital
methods so having identified the several
markers and prostate cancer as you can
see like s gene fusions pink one and
that Afghan at the infusion so this is
the first time a molecular
classification or prostate cancer have
been developed and it is not only that
individual markers they are identified
in a distinct subset of prostate cancer
recently there are many preclinical
studies have been completed showing and
the potential that some therapeutic
works targeting these s gene fusions
pink one or the rap one have been
developed
although these drugs are not ready for
the primetime pain gel use and there are
active research going on to bring it to
the clinic marketing base so given the
identification of several molecule
markers and prostate cancer identifying
distinct molecular subsets and with the
development of therapeutic inhibitors
targeting these molecules I think it is
very important that you know we need to
have a method that is much reliable and
it is very robust for the reliable
detection of these molecular markers in
a given tissue but it is a biopsy tissue
from the Mara sorry prostate cancer or
from the initial diagnostic biopsy or
from radical prostatectomy specimens we
should be able to you know classify
these patients based on this molecular
markers so when the drugs are available
for clinical use and I think it will be
very useful for identifying the
patient's carrying the specific markers
so that they can benefit by selecting
the appropriate therapy so with that
idea in mind you know we want to develop
a much more reliable in a kind of
detection method for the detection of
these molecule marks so here I'm showing
you a scheme a flow diagram if you want
to screen and prostate cancer markets as
you can see if you get a tissue biopsy
and a needle biopsy or prostitute a
prospect to me samples it goes to the
pathology examinations you know they do
the morphological analysis but there is
a cancer already normal so when it is a
cancer like if there is a very small
kind of a typical lesions you know that
may be additional staining can be done
to rule out whether they have cancer or
benign like doing this a high molecular
weight cytokeratin and pieces t3 and a
me fear staining to rule out and the
smaller typical clients so once you any
tissue specimen if it is confirmed with
a cancer as if we want to go for a
screening for molecular markers so like
you have the Earth's pink 1tb 180 before
a tvy when beta of all these markers so
one if you have to screen these markers
individually you have to do at least
five or six the different test rights if
we do it you know sometimes you know in
because of the limited amount of the
biopsy tissue you may not have the
luxury of having five or six lakhs okay
so in that situation you know you should
be able to scream more than one more
in La Habra session experiments here
other important thing that I want to
emphasize that these molecular markers
although we have several molecular
markers so far based on the research
what is available in the literature
these molecular markers express them
equally exclusive map meaning that you
don't find like more than one marker
that is expressing in a given tumor for
sight so you may see more than one
marker in different tumors for sighing
prostate because prostate being a
multifocal cancer but you don't see like
more than one marker expressing the same
a place like that
so that gives another very unique
advantage of actually developing
multiplex method it is easy to resolve
and interpret the results so for that
reasons you know like I mentioned that
we can develop both ISE and RNAs methods
like for Elkins pink one we have good
antibody we can do the hi-c then for ETV
180b for an ET b5 so far you know it is
fish fluorescent in situ hybridization
using the break of odd fish is the ideal
method but now we have developed the RNA
instead of hybridization for the tissue
level an expression of the SD infusions
so in the next slide I will show you
so here I'm showing the example of doing
both Heidi and rnh on individual slides
so here I'm showing the earth on and on
the needle biopsy so we did them you
know it's the chemistry but you will see
the specifics training one in the tumor
here I'm showing this pink one and a
needle biopsy showing specific
expression only the tumor and the both
organs pink one are done by AIC Here I
am showing ETB one expression by RNA
instead of hybridization as you can see
the specific only in the cancer but I
don't see any nonspecific staining in
the benign and similarly for ET before
we developed the R means two
hybridization methods which is actually
staining specific only in the tumor but
not the benign or stromal tissue so
which clearly shows that you know we
have individually tested these
immunohistochemistry antibodies and the
RNA into the hybridization probes for
for the reliable detection of the X gene
fusions and prostate cancer so we have
published this work and above yes ago so
you will find more details about the
probes that we used for the RNA into the
hybridization antibodies and how lovely
you can detect this inclusions by doing
both I and our nation prostate cancer so
I would like mine go through this paper
for more details so next I would like to
show an example how exactly we will
learn some new information or some
unexpected results you know when you
develop some new approaches so here I'm
showing one example so this is a
prostatectomy samples where there is a
tumor for sign that is change with
hematoxylin yoson and which we before
the army into the hybridization we
confirm this case was positive for ET
b12
by Phish so when we developed the
earnings to have decision makers we
strained this with our nation we were
able to see the good staining of RNA ish
all over most of the area and accepted
like there are two areas they are still
cancer where we did not find any
staining for the ETV one so next what we
did out of curiosity since these are all
still cancer but they are negative for
TB one so on a consecutive slide we did
the earthly ministry chemistry and we
found that the area that is negative for
etv one was positive for Earth so this
is what the first time we are able to
see that this is called inter tumor
heterogeneity because at the estrogen
level and hegemony the pathologies you
know they call it actually they are all
the same gauge and grade with not much
variation but there are two more areas
you know distinctly separate at the
molecular level and we were able to see
both both earth and et b1 present in
within the same at is called entire
tumor heterogeneity there we clearly
demonstrated that the presence of Earth
and ETV one wouldn't be the same tumor
for say but here as I mentioned before
these markers are mutually exclusive you
know so we are not seeing both et b1 and
Earth in the same cell but they are in
the two separate angels so this is this
emphasized in the need not only the
morphological classification it is
important to include the molecular
classification of the prostate cancer so
so now we are trying to understand what
it means when you have a patient we have
more than one marker presently tumors
you know whether it make the cancer more
aggressive or whether you'll have really
bad crimes or metastasis like that we
are trying to correlate the outcome or
the importance of this
one positive in prostate cancer so next
the important thing is and I so like
when we see this kind of intro tumor
heterogeneity so that makes us to think
that more than like about 87% of the
prostate cancer are multifocal 87
percent of the cases or multifocal
cancer only about 20% only about 12
percent of the cases or like a unique
focal disease so when you have a
prostate cancer with more than one tumor
for say so now we are asking the
questions whether they are the gentle
tentacle or the different okay so and
the most of the time the dominant or the
index nor do they call that the largest
nodule in a multifocal disease is
presumed to harbor the most aggressive
biological behavior and therefore
addicted the overall clinical behavior
of the prostate cancer but it is not
always the case that when you have the
largest tumor volume or the highest a
Gleason grade or the extra process or a
extension you may not find everything
within that single human audio sometimes
you will see more than one team of
course I makes have the you know you may
see largest tumor with their location
great but another tumor for say maybe
with the higher Gleason but the size may
be smaller than the induction audio like
that you know so you may not see like
everything within the single tumor for
say so
so therefore more than about one fifth
of the cases more than about one fifth
of the prostate cancer you may not find
the largest tumor volume or the highest
Gleason grade or the stage they are not
present within the same to not not you
nearly about one fifth of the cases so
sometimes you will find some smaller
kind of tumor fossa which is
with a Gleason nerdier that is at least
more than one glisteny higher than the
so-called the dominant or the index nor
you like that so it is for that reason
it is for that reason you know just by
studying the so called the dominant or
the index node you will be hot and give
all the complete information so now I
think it is there is a kind of lattice
of consensus that it is important to
consider even the secondary module also
to get an integrated analysis to make a
collective decision like that it is for
that reason there are many kind of
centers they started adopting the whole
mountain and prostate tissue analysis
rather than looking at one with the
dominant nor do you want the index not
like that so when you that idea in mind
we wanted to study the tumor
heterogeneity we wanted to study their
tumor heterogeneity in prostate cancer
as you know the heterogeneity in
prostate cancer is the reason for the
difficult diagnosis and sometimes
prognosis of the tumors when you have a
multifocal tumor like this you know you
have not only one tumor for sale you
have several tumor force I you know it
will be very difficult to understand
what is going on in these few more fossa
so the clinical significance of smaller
secondary tumors under the relationship
between the extent of molecular changes
and the metastatic potential Avenue your
tumor is not clearly understood okay as
I showed before you know you may be
having like a different kind of clonal
population of cells given by the
different type of molecular vibrations
in these cases so this for that reason
you know we have to have it is not only
on the hormone prostate cancer so we
have done a kind of pilot study few
years ago and where we showed that we
can demonstrate this type of tumor
heterogeneity
even in the needle biopsy samples as
well as you can see here as you can see
when you have a needle biopsy you know
you have one tumor force I in one end of
the tumor biopsy then another tumor
foresight this one so what we call it as
a discontinuous suppose okay when you
have these kind of two different forces
separated by a benign tissue how do you
interpret this are they coming from the
same tumor or they are coming from two
different kind of tumor and they are
separated kind of spatially separated by
benign or a stromal tissue so under
these circumstances you know what is
happening you know but these two tumors
are identical at the molecular level
are they different okay so what that
reasons when we did a study by using
only earth and [ __ ] one by D word
immunohistochemistry
we were able to demonstrate that about
13% about 13% of the needle biopsy had
about 1/4 say positive and distinct one
for size
okay so the end they are not the same
okay so you'll see one tumor is positive
forward and it has a tumor is positive
or so out of the 97 needle biopsy course
from 80 patients we found with the
involvement of 22 100% cancer
involvement we found about 25% of the
cases they had clonally distinct cancer
fossae and they are discordant and ozpin
like that so it is not only we don't
have to look at the whole more
prospective examples even and the needle
biopsy also we can demonstrate this type
of heterogeneity so it is for that
reasons you know we may so I think
combining more than one markers in a
multiplex approach will be some
important informations which we are not
aware of before so here I am showing an
example and into more money for
virginity detector than a needle biopsy
sample so here there is a one tumor for
sign at this end up
biopsy there's another tumor for sign in
this lab see here we did combined both
IC and RNAs where we see this was a is
positive for Ag and then the tumor is
positive for TB one so this is a very
clearly as you can see this is the zoom
in view of a TB one and the earth that
we can clearly demonstrated the two
different two distinct four sigh you
know distinct for a different molecule
abrasions one is order is for et b1
separated by the hybrid P normal tissue
so this is the type of molecule I can't
rigidity that you can identify by
combining both the IC and the RNA in
situ hybridization so therefore so like
I discussed before we have these
multiple markets okay so based on the
availability of the reagents and we were
able to kind of improve the detection
approach so that we will be able to
detect at least four markers in a single
hybridization right now okay so we can
combine both ASC and RNA is we have two
markers for I see that is Earth and the
speed one these two can be direct by LC
and it'll be one and it'll be four by
rnase so we will be able to detect all
these four markers on the same tissue by
doing a more sequential hybridization of
RNA is first and followed by the
immunised chemistry so this is a
three-day protocol so when we do it
manually so first today we will do the
antigen retrieval and do the RNA in situ
hybridization and the second day and you
can detect the RNA ish and then do the
primary IH antibody you can leave it
overnight and the next day into that the
third day period is you so you saw that
you'll be able to see all the four
signals so here is important that always
undo the RNA is first followed by the IC
don't do the IC first and RNA is so you
will not be able to see the RNAs
okay so here I'm showing an example
where on the tissue microarray we are
fortunate to have like the tumors that
are positive for the Alpha markers so
this is the tissue micro array where we
hybridized both iousy and RNAs and so we
need earth ET v 1e TB course pink on all
the food markers and we were able to
detect simultaneously by doing the
sickle cell hybridization of our
distance AC here I'm showing clearly
that is a tumor sample that is positive
for ad before as you can see the strong
staining and this pink one that is as
from staining more heterogeneous and
this is the tumor that is positive for
here and there is another tumor that is
positive for this giving one so so that
will be able to detect all the four
markers you know nothing looks like so
this is I think this approach is very
useful especially when you are limited
with the amount of the tissue that is
available for hybridization see like if
you have a biopsy tissue from bone mass
or lymph node biopsy or a needle biopsy
you know which has a very small amount
of tumor you know so you don't have the
battery up cutting multiple slice so you
may not be so if you want to screen all
the four markers you don't want waste
four slides you know we see with
availability of a single tissue you'll
be able to get this kind of valuable
information okay next this is not only
on the daily biopsy or on the teaming
here I am showing a whole mount prostate
tissue where we were able to see there
are five different tumor Fawcett is the
multifocal prostate cancer with the five
different tumor fossa and initially we
screened this tumor with the and the
pink one
Duvall is see with that we were able to
see the so called the dominant tumor
nodule just a negative for both are can
speak one
steamer for say was positive for her
gand this is positive for [ __ ] one this
tumor for the negative and this tumor
was it was positive for ETB one which
was done on a fancy dish like this area
was positive for TB one so here we
clearly demonstrated that out of the
five the individual tumor for side there
are spatially separated by the benign or
the stromal tissue and they have a
distinct driver molecular aberrations as
if we know that the safety inclusions or
the driver molecular vibrations in
prostate cancer and we see see that the
tumors offer a different and given grace
like the ERG fossa is like a Gleason 6
and whereas the tumour process that is
positive on ETV one is more like a
Geisha
7 so we and the so called the dominant
or the index Nadya loses again it has a
case and six part okay so given then
further we have done actually p10 is e
on the same cases where we found the
pigeon was deleted only in the tumor
forces that is positive for e TV one
with the guide is with the high B's and
great whereas all of the tumor was a
gram negative the pigeon was intact like
then we will be able to kind of develop
or gather such a valuable information
just by combining both communities to
chemistry and RNA ish okay so now it is
important okay so you cannot one can ask
the questions and when you have this
multifocal team work with multiple
driver aberrations which humor for say
is kind of biologically important which
is going to actually find contribute for
the better status or the aggressive
nature or the treatment like that and
also how these patients are going to
respond to this kind of treatment like
that okay so I think these are all and
some of the questions that are we are
actually beginning to address by using
this type of approach so so here and I
want to emphasize the point that and
although the earth at ETV one drawn to
the same
family st-jean family but at the
biological level they behave entirely
different way so the earth and ETV one
they control a common transcription
network but largely in an abortion
opposing fish okay so the earth actually
negatively the glades the handle
intercepted transcription program and
ETV one cooperates with a are signaling
by favoring activation of a or
transcriptional program and ctv one
expression but not that of earth
promotes autonomous testosterone
production ET b one but not appropriate
expression of a at par with genes as
well as being involved in sterile biases
and ET b one supports the development of
invasive carcinoma under the background
of reagent locks okay so the distinct
biology of ET v one associated with
prostate cancer suggests that this
disease class may require new
therapeutics and directional to
underlying programs controlled by the ET
be one so this clearly emphasized the
need okay to classify the tumors based
on the molecule abrasions and also this
s genes family you know our involved in
prostate cancer they are expressed in a
mutually exclusive manner in the
different or different tumor cause i so
it is important and they work in and
tell me in a different molecular
mechanisms so the drugs targeting these
molecules you know we cannot use
although they bond to a famous family
you cannot have to treat all of them as
the same so we have to develop in
celebrating molecular targets so these
are also more being information that we
are learning out of this by doing this
molecular hydrogen analysis and this is
the new beginning where you know we can
actually use this informations and to
develop our new ant in my strategies
okay I think with that I have
convincingly shown you the power of the
combined a minister chemistry
our is how you can actually study these
tumor heterogeneity in prostate cancer
as I mentioned that this approach is not
limited only to prostate cancer this is
and this approach can be adapted to any
other solid cancer as long as you have
this distinct molecular markers and you
know the red application of these
markers and the expression pattern and I
think with this kind of approach we
don't have to have this sophisticated
method or anything like that we will be
able to learn a lot of new information
so because this type of tumor molecular
heterogeneity has been studied by
different approaches like the
next-generation sequencing it's like
people have done like micro dissection
of individual tumor fossae they have
done next-gen sequencing and they have
demonstrated that there are multiple
molecular aberrations you know with the
inserts and deletions gene field
multiple gene fusions are occurring in
different people for say but those
studies did not reveal any targetable
molecule aberrations so therefore we
decided to stick with the already
established molecular markers which are
known to be driver molecular operations
in prostate cancer and the drugs are in
the preclinical studies showing the
potential of developing in a specific
therapeutic drugs a targeting each
molecule I think when this works in over
into the clinic when they have the
therapeutic potential I think the
approach that I described the combined
is an RNA ich will be the powerful
approach for the early diagnosis of the
needle biopsy or the prostate metastatic
biopsy for characterization of these
tumors for the presence or absence of
this molecule markets which is a very
powerful kind of approach ok so next I
would like to move on and to show some
of the non-coding RNA targets in
prostate cancer as we know that
non-coding RNAs you know it is very
gentle motion that there is non-coding
RNA that not coding for any protein but
it is not 100%
true because it has been shown that
recently there are many encoding armies
they do in the court for some small
proteins what we call it as micro
peptides no it has been shown recently
by saw the work by dr. Eric Olson so
they're not coding armies you cannot
perfectly say that they are strictly
non-coding they some of them are do
making proteins and eventually
antibodies can be developed but right
now I know the lack of information so we
generally use the RNA in the
hybridization approach to detect the
non-coding RNA expression in tissues
okay because the function of the
non-coding RNA transporter kind of
generalized mechanism like a non-coding
RNAs act to a variety of mechanisms such
as remodelling achromatic
transcriptional activation putting in
division post-transcriptional
modifications or they can function as a
decoy elements or the more that function
is born the regulation of other protein
coding genes so given importance because
there are several prostate cancer
specific non-coding rnas have been
identified like a peak at TCF 3 and a
slant one care sp1 like that is or the
prostate cancer specific and coding RNAs
so we have developed some methods to see
the expression pattern of this
non-coding RNA at the tissue level so I
think without the are names to the
hybridizations way then we can build PCR
or some other quantitative method to
study the expressions but if you want to
see the spaceship just preserving the
spatial morphology of the tumor and you
want us as the expression pattern I
think our needs the hybridization is the
best approach so here I'm showing an
example where we identified a new gene
fusion involving a
KSP one here we developed an RNA into
the hybridization program be sure that
very clear were kind of tissue-specific
expression of the RNA molecule only in
the high place and we're like purposely
our three plus four edges and word
prostate cancer but they are completely
negative in the benign prostate and also
in the low gray a long list and a
prostate so we found this kind of
non-coding RNA that it's expressed only
in the hedges in that specific manner
then next the PCA three is a very good
non-coding RNA that is a prostate cancer
specific it is expressed almost about
ninety or ninety percent of the prostate
cancer which is and be used as a marker
but it's important is that the spca
three RNA transcript can be detected in
the urine it is not only PCA three the
TMP RSS to earth gene fusion can also be
fusion transcript can also be affected
in the green so recently there was a
test that have been developed and it was
approved by the FDA and for the PCA
three huge introduction of the PCA three
at the University of Michigan there was
a new tests that have been developed for
patients who has elevated PSA and those
patients by non-invasive methods we can
detect both the PCA 3 and the TMP are
assessed ordering so the and they have
developed a score so that we can
actually predict the high-risk nature of
the prostate so that you can avoid the
pit biopsy type of things ok so here the
essence of time I not be able to go
through details so here I want to show
you that we developed this our means the
hybridization proof for the PCA three
that we have shown that you know so
there are tumors with the different
level of experience see always 100% of
the team are showing the PCA three
non-coding RNA we have seen kind of
cases ranging from 5 percent to 100
percent of the team
expressing the pc3 but in this example
I'm showing that is almost every tumor
area is showing the level expression of
the PCF Lida mastered by the coding RNA
and we have actually published a paper
combining a study where we were able to
correlate the tissue level expression of
the pca 3 with the Judean lab ok we were
able to show the concordance between the
urine and tissue level Ojai concordance
but there are about five to ten percent
of the cases we do found some discordant
expression we were not able to
holistically like when the tissue level
may be high but you may not see and
after the curing on the car wise words
more in the urine but not the tissues so
we have to learn more about how the
harness process from the tissues and
coming to URI so that is this or so much
it is but in the majority of the cases
being able to correlate the tissue level
expression and the unit level expression
tc3 so please read this paper for more
details and next we are coming close to
the presentation here i want to show you
that the RNA is to hybridization method
that i have actually shown is not only
immature for prostate cancer and
recently put out a publication showing
that the ET b 1e TV for an e DB v our
names of the vibration can be used and
the diagnosis of the yeah that's a comas
wherever you see the hell old expression
of all these three markers combining so
this all these three markers you know as
I showed you before we don't have good
anybody's only army is the best method
and this can be used for their clinical
diagnosis of this very bizarre format
and it is not only like protein coding
and genes or non-coding RNAs even some
of the macro cell carcinoma virus can
also be you know detected by using the
earnings the hybridization this is the
paper that people this recently so these
are all the application of RNA
I told you before this not limited to
one particular application or prostate
but depending on the biological question
that any was together you may have you
can actually easily adapt its RNA into
the high precision metal in your map
based on some of the issues that I have
discussed okay
so in summary I would like to show that
our names of the hybridization is a
novel approach for the detection objects
in creations in prostate cancer arrghh
[ __ ] won a duel I see it will be needs
a new subtype of prostate cancer with
the urban speak on expression in the
same or an independent a tumor for sign
and by combining dual IHC and the dual
RNAs identify new subsets of prostate
cancer with the dual or triple SG
arrangements then analysis of the
hormone process samples the will the
presence of even smaller chemicals a
with the heterogeneous molecular markers
and the distinct biology of its distinct
biology of the S gene associated
prostate cancer suggest that each this
is class may require new therapies
underlying programs controlled by the
different molecules the combined IHC and
RNAs is an our approach to screen
molecular ablation prostate cancer and
it is important that the combining so I
didn't assume some time I did not
improve the slide but anyone who is
interested please email me that we can
do both DNA fish and RNA ich on the same
slide if anyone is a classical please
contact me I'll be able to share with
you more information about this I didn't
have time to enjoy that particular slide
but we have successfully performed this
in the inefficient patient the same
slide so with that I would like to
conclude my presentation by
acknowledging the people who are
involved study so all the information
about the is in RNA ich
you know we have developed this method
in my laboratory and all the examples
that I have shown are actually from the
is performed in our laboratory and the
all the ISE and RNA is worth I was done
by the highly talented staff in my group
is Sharon Koskinen and of course every
extremely talented showed up it's kind
of new procedures and we demonstrated
expense working well and I want to thank
the pathologist who are involved the
study dr. Millis good - Shawn Williams
and a denture who are extremely helpful
with providing the valuable tissue
material for our studies and I want to
personally thank professor that money
man who's the chair of the department of
urology who has pioneered in the robotic
prostatectomy first a surgical removal
of the prostate by using the da Vinci
robotic system and it has been extremely
you know kinda helpful you know
by providing excellent support and help
by providing the technical information
and the such a specimen of all the cases
is involved the study and our work is
supported by funding from an a devotee
and extra Foundation and the startup one
from the Henry Ford so then I'm thankful
to dr. Chen I am from the Michigan trans
to them and Center for translational
technology will be mr. Michigan where I
still work as an adjunct assistant
professor and he was actually extremely
helpful for developing this type of our
nation during the early stages of its
development so I want to thank everyone
so with that I would like to conclude my
presentations and I'll be happy to
answer any questions thank you
thank you dr. Pilate saw me for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appears
on your screen and Clank understand
button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is how many
RNA targets can be detect with dual is h
IH 3 as I have shown you in the
presentation right now we have developed
the methods for routine use by manual
method we can detect up to four
molecular targets like a 2 targets by
ISC and then to target by our names to
hybridizations so we have perfected the
method for the detection of four
molecules in a single experiment all the
four molecules can be seen by the
brightful application so if you add the
fluorescence we will be able to add more
markers but if I think if anyone wants
to kind of restrict their analysis only
by for right field applications right
now I think the limitation is for four
and yes we can go for additional at
least for another one or two but right
now without any issues we are able to do
four markers
under prices thank you
our next question is can dual is h IH C
will be performed on an automated
machine yes yes I have mentioned in the
presentation so we have optimized the
protocol for the Ventana discovery XT
which is a research instrument and even
advanced to sell diagnosis they are
actually supporting and the reagents and
the protocol for using the automated
went on assistance and I think they have
another instrument like I don't remember
it could be a dark or like you know the
other system can also be used for the
automated RNAs and I see thank you our
next question is can I do that ihdr a
pers and then the RNA scope is H acid no
strictly not because if you do that I
see first and because of the high
temperature and other language and the
table procedures you may and kind of
spoil the integrity of the RNA by doing
the antigen retrieval for IH c so I
would recommend strictly recommend do
RNA into the realization first then
we'll see thank you our next question is
can I combine the base go p-- assay with
IH c I think so I have not personally I
have not done this experiment in my
laboratory but I think this question can
be best answered by the technical
support from the advance itself
Diagnostics but based on the limited
information that I gather I think it is
possible to do is e and the base coat
yes my next question is are there any
recommendations for performing a dual is
h IH c assay so as I have discussed in
my presentations and it is important to
know that targets of the target or the
location of your targets like whatever
the market that are used for IAC whether
they are going to be like membrane or
nuclear or cytoplasmic like that you
know it is important to have the period
knowledge of the location of the target
molecules and also the level of
expression and make sure that you know
if you are looking for a market that is
X
if you are externally when you are
combining like three or four markers
make sure that they are all kind of
Express at a decent level if you are
looking for a kind of very low
expression target sometimes you know it
may be challenging to interpret the
results as I would is important that
make sure you have some clear knowledge
about individual markers when you are
doing the combined is in RNA is the
location and also it is important that
as I highlighted in my presentation you
want to test individual markers first
make sure that each antibody or the RNA
probes are performing well individually
in a separate experiments don't combine
with is your RNA is if it is RNA scope
just to RNAs alone make sure that the
probe is working and giving the expected
results before combining with a AC so I
think I would recommend these are some
of the important steps and that you may
want to follow when you're developing do
all IAC and RNAs procedures thank you
our next question is how many flights
can an RNA scope can't run I think it's
a defense I think the amount of reagents
and the hope that are provided in the
kid I think one can easily perform up to
like a twenty five to thirty slice but
it can be stretched and depending upon
the size of the tissue that you are
using sometimes you may have a large
size tumor rather larger tissue size so
you may have to use a little more
reagents if all of them are like nearly
biopsy you may be able to stretch up to
like 40 or 50 slides so I think the
minimum I would say 25 maximum you can
go up to 40 depending on the size of the
tissue
thank you our next question is can I use
my own situ hybridization probes yes you
can develop your own instead of
hybridization probes but you'll be using
entirely different protocol if you want
to use the advanced of self diagnostics
and my third because you have to use
their proprietary probe development
system for developing the probes because
they were able to develop the antigens
all of your probes and they develop up
to like 10 to 20 C pairs and they're
they provide more specific hybridization
avoiding nonspecific signals and the Z
pairs that they are provide and they are
specific and each Z probe has to
hybridize in pace only when the hybrid
compared you will be able to amplify and
those targets in a subsequent
amplification steps like that that will
increase more specificity and the
sensibility for base but here the probes
if you develop your own RNA probe by
doing the anti sense kind of robust
transcriptions yes you can develop it
but I don't think you sing the ACD bio
protocol or the reagents you may not be
able to do the experiment for your poops
then you have to go over to entirely
different vendor and like Omega are some
other companies you know they provide
the RNA detection reagents for this type
of probes so one has to be careful when
you are actually trying to use your home
brew water custom reports you cannot use
the ACD biomatter we wanted a place
anybody you have to have the pub and
entire rated by AC by
thank you our last question is how long
does the RNA scope athlete take to
perform normally you will be able to
complete the RNAs experiment on the same
day if you start in the morning by end
of the day you'll be able to complete
the RNA experiment this is by manual
method so if you have the automated
machines it takes about I think six to
seven hours and the machine so when you
are using the automated method you just
put the reagents and the slides of the
machines and in - it takes care of
automatically it takes about six to
seven hours but if you do use the manual
procedures you'll be able to complete on
the same day by starting regularly in
the morning or later 9 o'clock by 4 o
clock you'll be able to have a slide so
but in between when you do the manual
procedures it is really hands-on but of
course you will have in between as many
incubations within an hour 30 minutes or
particle names like that but it is
heavily hands-on but you will be able to
complete the procedure on the same day I
would like to once again thank dr. Anna
losev on Palani Sun do you have any
final comments I want to thank all the
all the participants who will listen to
hundreds presentations please feel free
to contact me and I think that my email
address is provided in the first slide
so please email me for any specific
technical questions we will be happy to
share the protocol or send me an email
with any specific questions I will be
happy to answer any questions if I'm not
able to answer I will direct your
questions to the technical service
department of the advanced Excel
diagnosis and you will get the help
thank you very much for your time and
listening to the presentations
thank you dr. Anna La Ceiba
Palani Sami for your presentation I
would also like to thank advanced
diagnostics for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's web
so be available for on-demand viewing
through February of 2018 yours even
email from labradorite um you know in
this webcast will be available for
replay they show that announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye